What do you think? Can we only learn through
direct experience, or also from studying others?
Psychologist Albert Bandura came
up with an interesting experiment
to answer that exact question and form a theory.
Bandura came up with the social
learning theory in the 1960s,
a time dominated by scholars who
didn’t believe Bandura's idea
and argued that learning was always the result
of classical and operational conditioning.
To prove that children can
learn by mere observation,
Bandura came up with the Bobo Doll
Experiments - a set of controversial studies,
which involved preschool children,
adult models and a stand-up punch doll.
In the first set of experiments, the children were
seated alone in a corner of the room. From there
they observed an adult actor aggressively kicking
and scolding the Bobo doll for about 10 minutes.
Afterwards, the same child was put
into a new playroom where another
adult deliberately frustrated the child by
taking away the toys the child played with.
The frustrated child was then put back into the
room with the Bobo doll where Bandura and his
team made the following 3 observations:
1. Children who initially saw the adult
punching the doll, often copied the behavior.
2. Boys were three times more likely to do so.
3. Boys reproduced the behavior twice as often,
if they observed a man do it compared to boys
who observed a female actor. Girls were
also more influenced by same-sex models.
To find out if movies would have the same effect,
Bandura let some children watch the
model live, and others watch it on video,
or as a cartoon animation. As all
three groups showed similar responses,
Bandura concluded that children imitate others
regardless of where they have seen the behavior.
In the last variation of the experiments,
Bandura wanted to know if the children would
act differently when the models were reinforced
or punished for their behavior towards the doll.
Now, the children first
saw the actor hit the doll,
and then observed another adult enter the room.
This second adult would then react to the actor.
These last results showed that it did not make
much of a difference to the children whether the
aggressor was praised or not. However, the kids
who saw that the model was punished, displayed
much less aggression later, an effect which
was especially true for girls. In other words,
seeing others being rewarded does not
necessarily motivate us to copy their behavior.
Seeing others being punished, on the other hand,
can significantly diminish our will to copy it.
The fact that Bandura was able to prove that
children also learn by observing others,
was a breakthrough in psychology.
As a consequence of his findings,
scholars and government officials argued
that we should ban violence in films and
games. Others suggested that the Bobo Doll
studies are not studies of aggression,but
rather show that the children are simply motivated
by the desire to please adults or act like them.
Bandura and his co-author
Richard Walters later defined
five key tenets of the Social Learning Theory:
1. Learning is a cognitive process
that takes place in a social setting.
2. Learning can occur by observing a
behavior AND the consequences of such
3. Learning can happen without an observable
change in behavior, because we may learn
without displaying what we have learned.
4. Reinforcements play a role but are
not entirely responsible for learning.
5. Cognition, behavior, and environment
all mutually influence each other — a
process called reciprocal determinisms.
Bandura, who in college attended a
psychology course only to kill time,
soon became passionate about the topic and then
one of most cited psychologists in history.
About reality, he said: "Most of the images
of reality on which we base our actions
are really based on vicarious experience."
What do you think? How much of your
learning comes from observing others?
And if you learn socially, who
are your greatest teachers?
This and all other Sprouts' videos are
licensed under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses or
to start projects - and
today, thousands already do!
To learn how it works and download this
video without Ads or background music,
checkout our website or
read the description below.
If you want to support our
mission and help change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.